hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
we are back again for part two in our
list of 100 Pro tips that we've picked
up from watching those professionals
over on Twitch sorry this one took
longer than expected nine of the plan
tips didn't work in season 5 so I was
forced to go back to stocking those pros
again
luckily season 5 has loads of new tips
to master there's a small issue in
replay theater which leaves fields in
this weird transparent state but we'll
try and use that to our advantage
so let's do this the all-terrain cart
arrived in season 5 and there's a ton of
things we can do with it to get the edge
in battle my personal favorite is
loading it with c4 and tracking down
unknown enemies if you are the one with
the c4 be sure to jump off the 80k or
you'll blow yourself to pieces your
teammates of course won't be hurt in the
slightest it's also a good idea to use
this technique to destroy the structures
your enemies are in the c4 damage on
buildings has been reduced but it's
still done worth it if you can't get an
ATK the shopping cart can be used in the
same way depending on where you place
the c4 it's possible to improve the
blast radius as this glitch happens the
c4 floats meters away from the vehicle
the golf buggy is hard to resist and
it's the perfect opportunity to bait
people they'll come running for it
either you see far from earlier or
simply wait for them to get near enough
and wreck them by the way these are my
son's first eliminations in fortnight's
he's a bush wookie I can't decide if I'm
proud or not not bad for a four-year-old
the best place to do this is in loot
lake they'll bog themselves down trying
to reach the hallow'd vehicle and then
it moves bloody slow in the water at
first
oh another use for that cut one hit
smashing into llamas and it's possible
to pick up loot by simply riding over it
oh I'm sure you've noticed the roof on
the golf buggy is a bouncer yeh but it
doesn't prevent ball damage bugger you
could use it to get the edge in battle
like this
you can jump into the cart from height
if you are slightly missing the roof try
to spam the button to get onboard the
cart I tend to use it to reach rifts
speaking of risks when using these brain
farts be aware how low you can go before
your parachute is opened it criminally
low to the ground by picking a quiet
parachute you can dive bomb opponents
and kill them before they even know
what's happening I've been trying to
figure out a way to cancel this out and
all I've got is to stay aware of the
ear-shattering noise in the sky the
noise of someone using a rift should
pique your interests and the quick look
up when you hear the commotion will keep
you prepared for rift dive bombers the
ability to look through our edits has
sadly been removed but there is just
enough room to look through the gaps
with a little practice the only
structure it's possible to look through
completely is the pyramid if you see a
pyramid in a high place it's likely
someone is in there using it to survey
their surroundings and using the pyramid
for head glitch covering fights is still
a great tactic most shots will strike
the top of the pyramid and not your head
you're basically taking advantage of the
inaccuracies in hit detection oh and
remember the speed parachute from the
last episode there's a quicker way to
achieve this effect now here it is
let's look at soccer balls and throw
balls an additional way to use stink
bombs is to throw them at a downed
teammate the opposition can't get close
enough to take their gear and visibility
is greatly reduced so if you're looking
enough they'll survive long enough to be
raised another way to use it is like a
catwalk and guide your friends into are
away from battle they'll simply think
you are terrible at throwing nades do
you ever find yourself constantly
shooting down on a turtling opponent
have you tried laying c4 on the roof
don't blow it up right away keep
knocking down the tiles and eventually
it will fall into their lair now it's
time to blow it
[Applause]
speaking of turtling people are now so
used to looking for those one by ones
with a pyramid on top as they know
they'll likely be a person inside or
better yet some precious love left
behind well this means it can also be
used to bait aggressive players allowing
you to get the high ground and destroy
them are planting c4 inside and timing
it right c4 can be ridiculous let's talk
about double turtling those spam weapons
are insanely frustrating and getting
five seconds to pop a shield could mean
survival therefore we can try double
turtling it's like the normal method but
includes an extra layer well 3 in fact
this is only for scenarios where the
opponent has the high ground but in our
tests it offers the perfect amount of
time to pop a full shield or a couple of
minutes we've also found that your
opponent gives up after breaking the
first three tiles which should allow
time to chug-chug here's an annoying
trend which is currently happening in
Battle Royale editing the launch part or
ramp tile a fraction of a second after
jumping this is how I first encountered
it wicka wicka push run to
this tactic is used to prevent enemies
using your ramp but it's used to greet
people in 50 versus 50 so be aware of
that one destroying the launch pad is a
solid tactic though I personally prefer
to throw a nade and destroy the ramp as
I'm jumping but this new tactic saves a
bullet or two as bouncers drop in threes
the best ways to get distance from the
storm first get some height by using two
bounces and then use the last one to
throw you in the direction you desire
and if you're a complete madman use this
tactic to catapult yourself into your
fault another use for those bouncers is
to chain them together to travel large
distances like this let's go back to
traps for a second I showed this trap
technique in the last episode but I
didn't actually talk about it but it
still works in season five place the
traps behind a ramp and watch people
murder eyes themselves to put this into
context I have six kills in one game
because of one of these murder ramps an
old way to cross loot lake I completely
missed in the last episode is to cross
it underneath it won't get you anywhere
quickly but it will scare the bejesus
out of some players and occasionally
it's actually useful the new Viking
Valhalla has ridiculous materials on
offer the spear racks are worth up to 17
wood in a single ax wing these things
here are also worth criminal amounts of
wood so if you're the last survivor here
smash the place to smithereens did you
notice that Viking bow Hallows buildings
offer over two traps throw one down here
and you'll be surprised how useful they
can be
the ultimate ramp rush technique has
been updated to involve double
protection two ramps one while one floor
it takes so much time to master but if
you're king of the tripods this is for
you on the flip side of that when you
get the high ground and find someone has
gone full try hard keep in mind a single
nade will bring down the whole thing and
now the materials have been weakened
especially wood only a few bullets from
a drum gun can break down their rush if
you find yourself falling to your death
and you're quick enough to react it's
possible to place down a ramp and
bouncer to save yourself that can be
difficult with a controller so you could
deliberately place down a ramp near your
tower so when you start to fall you can
use a bouncer as your building is
crashing down other ways to get down
look look at this one it's ridiculous a
chap I play with Cod Zack GG uses this
technique to get down from a build
battle creating a window in a wall and
bouncing down from window to window
here's my attempt yeah I'm pretty shitty
of this game I know this one's a cop-out
but stay aware of the weapon updates the
meta change is so bloody often as I'm
writing this my teammates currently take
a drum gun over a legendary scale sounds
ridiculous I know but we currently live
in the era of spam weapons I'm sure that
won't be the case for long but knowing
the best loadout is imperative just
watch a few pro streamers or videos like
this one or hopping to chat and that's
what the matter is
if the streamer doesn't answer one of
the community will
gap peeking have made a huge return in
season 5 as a head glitching
is almost impossible right now use the
gaps to spy through and quickly stand up
to hit a head shot quickly editing walls
to include windows is once again on the
rise as it once again surprises players
I find it's a high-risk high-reward
tactic be sure to edit the wall back
again afterwards if you miss your shot
we're at a point in the meta where
pyramids are becoming used more and more
for example this ramp strategy ramp jump
pyramid basically you're jumping from
ramp to ramp it also offers additional
cover should someone quickly shoot at
you but ultimately this is for speed
rushing it has zero integrity and you
will fall to your death
44:10 once again be taken down in a few
swings very useful to know the last two
are specifically for console players I
recently made a video about the
advantages of using a pro controller and
the great counter-argument to this was
button reassignment on console changing
the jump button to R 3 can be
revolutionary to some people allowing
jumping and aiming in one movement and
speaking of console depending on the TV
you are using you may be at an unfair
disadvantage due to input lag this is
the amount of time the controller
commands take to affect the on-screen
action some TVs especially the bigger
ones include processing which can see up
to half a second of delay in movement
and reaction on screen but blood ly
regardless of your reaction times you
are already behind so if you're winning
on a 50 inch LED TV you're a beast and
will crush everyone on a monitor with
low latency if anybody's interested in
latency or how screens and
post-processing or input lag give me a
show in the comments and I'll try to
make you a deal anyway there we go all
the tips currently out there for season
5 of fortnight battle royale I'll be
sure to keep stocking those pros and
come back very soon with more tips from
those people lucky enough to be paid to
play video games they really a huddle up
into the dream I'm Adam from Playstation
grenade it's been a bloody pleasure I'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]